hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna share with you the power of
intermittent fasting
okay now intermittent fasting is a tool
it's not a diet it doesn't tell you what
to eat it's a pattern of eating okay
it's as a pattern of eating and not
eating that you it's not about cutting
calories it's just changing when you eat
and when you don't eat okay so that's
all going to talk about so why would you
want to do this anyway because it is one
if not the most important factors in
weight loss okay let's talk about why
because it triggers two main hormones in
your body the most powerful ones one is
growth hormone which is anti-aging and
the most powerful fat burning hormone
there are six fat burning hormones
growth hormone is the most powerful fat
burning hormone to protect your muscles
to build Mutt lean body mass and also
just to lose actual fat okay and then
you have insulin insulin is also a very
powerful hormone in that it actually
will help you store that if you want to
gain weight which you don't want to do
that you want to lose weight but here's
the thing and the presence of insulin
you cannot lose weight it's such a
dominating hormone it will block growth
hormone so it's the hormone that makes
you fat it's the hormone that gives you
the gut if you see someone with a fat
gut they have too much insulin so these
are the two powerful hormones that
you're going to influence now let's look
at what's happening this tool or
technique can really heal insulin
resistance where you have the pancreas
pumping out way more insulin than you
need five to seven times because what
happens when you have too much insulin
the cells start blocking it and then
your body doesn't get the return
communication so it's like talking your
child and they have ear plugs you're
going to increase your volume because
the person is ignoring you there's no
two-way communication so but the
pancreas doesn't get the feedback that
the insulin is connecting its sends more
insulin
through the channel so you have a
situation where you have resistance of
insulin it's not working low insulin in
the cell low glucose but then you have
high amounts of insulin in other places
which is very destructive causes
pre-diabetes it creates a lot of
problems okay
so what we want to do is we want to
start where you're at and then graduate
this way over time it's kind of like
there's different levels of intermittent
fasting from not intermittent fasting to
some serious fat burning over here so
let's say you start with five meals a
day or six meals to six meals a day you
have breakfast lunch snacks some people
do breakfast snack lunch snack dinner
snack right that's a lot of people that
do that the principle of intermittent
fasting hormone only is that every time
you eat you spike insulin see people
have thought that only when you eat
carbohydrates you spike insulin no no
eating in general will increase insulin
no regardless of what you eat
even if snack you if it's healthy so we
have a situation where this person's
spiking insulin all day long our bodies
they're not designed to eat and graze
all day long so we want to switch to
three meals a day with no snacks okay so
that's the first step three mils a day
no snacking the ability to go from one
meal to the next without being hungry
involves eating more fat okay so you
have to add more fat to that meal I'm
gonna put some links down what to eat
but this is this videos not about what
to eat it's about the pattern so you get
three meals here and then if you want to
take it to the next level and burn even
more fat you want to do a pattern of 16
to 8 16 hours of fasting an eight-hour
window of eating okay so let's say you
get up in the morning and you're not
hungry well don't eat wait until you're
hungry the ideal situation is to go for
hours when you wake up for at least four
hours before you eat the first meal so
let's say you're you get you eat at 10
o'clock
okay in the morning so and you got up at
6 so that means that your last meal is
going to be
six o'clock at night so you have an
eight-hour window where this you might
get up and eat at 8:00 then you might
eat at 8:00 at night so you really
haven't given enough fasting a little
bit in between but not the real power of
in a minute fasting is through the night
and in the morning and that actually at
like at nighttime when you're sleeping
and then in the morning that's when you
really have the uninterrupted serious
fat burning not necessarily is much
between the meals but it is a factor so
that's why we want sixteen hours of
fasting with this so we try to keep that
window and you have your three meals
okay does that make sense now if we want
to take it even further and really turn
on the fat-burning you we want to go to
two meals but we want a window of 20
hours of fasting you know what that
would do to your your waistline your
stomach so we go for 20 hours fasting
and only four hour window of eating so
we want we want to get up and wait until
let's say twelve o'clock or one have the
first meal and then have the next meal
four hours later so let's say you get
you eat at 1:00 then your next meal is
at 5:00 okay so you have four hours
there where you basically you ate but
then you have 20 hours of serious fat
burning if we then add in a minute fat
exercise to that high-intensity interval
training then it's it's over that would
be the icing on the cake well maybe I
shouldn't say I see in the game that's
gonna be the meat and potatoes no don't
don't listen to me but the point is that
it's going to take some time to
transition over to these different
levels okay don't think it happens in a
minute if you've destroyed your
metabolism through dieting or the HCG
diet which is 500 calories or some other
stress event then what's going to happen
it's going to take some time to
gradually kind of move over to the next
one
but you'll get comfortable we don't want
you to be headachy and have a lot of
side effects between the meals so you
want to overtime in this this transition
from here to here could take you know
three weeks but this one could take a
month or two or even three months before
you get to this point go taking them
longer but then you're really burning
fat okay so I just wanted to cover what
the powerful the power of this what it
is and how you would do it starting here
and gradually over here all right put
your comments below thanks for watching
you know I just wanted to take a moment
out to thank you for your amazing
feedback that you guys are giving me
it's just mind-blowing the successes the
winds I created a link down below so you
can actually type out your full success
story and if you have a before-and-after
with weight loss that would be awesome
and if you don't have a success with
weight but other things just put an
image of yourself and your personal
success story and I would love to read
it and also share it with others so I
want to just thank you in advance for
doing that but there's a link down below
fill it out I can't wait to read it